AJ Pritchard lovely to talk to you today
AJ I'm really sorry to hear this news
this must be a real shock to the
strictly family
yeah I think it's really hard
considering like you Len Goodman is
synonymous with Strictly Come Dancing
from the beginning and really such a
a person that has done so much for
boreham Latin dancing and really kind of
like he would be even when I was younger
it'd be like boreham Latin dance and
we've still got the stigma you're kind
of wearing bright colors Sparky outfits
lots of fake tan and by this kind of
modern age right now Len Goodman kind of
brought no it's good to be a born land
dancer look it's work you work hard it
is you get to dance with beautiful
ladies and to think one person in the UK
has changed the opinion of saying the
number seven out loud you all you I'll
never think of number seven again
anymore there's always going to be a
seven
um he's just done so much and it is
really a celebration for Len because he
has just brought so much positivity so
many people Strictly Come Dancing itself
is a light and Len was definitely that
that magic that made it so well known
and aside from Strictly you have had a
links within family connection didn't
you you knew him before strictly
yeah so my dad would always be um
judging with Len traveling the world
it'd always be them stories so then the
irony of me actually become a
professional dancer and working with Len
um was hilarious a bit of a weird mix
from my dad kind of um change of roles
there but Len has always been himself
and I think the one thing that I always
get asked is that was Len Goodman the
same person on and off camera and it is
so so nice to me say yes Len is just Len
that infectious smile when you'd see him
on lens lens and you see a little
twinkle in his tooth that was him like
it was so good especially when he did
the arena tours like he thrived upon
that energy especially on Strictly with
12 million people live on a Saturday
yeah you can't beat it and then you
never knew what comment he was going to
come out with from pickle my walnuts to
well God knows it was always something
different
and and that you know his personality
his warmth his twinkle how important
would you say that was to the overall
success of the program and why people
just really enjoyed it being a big part
of their Saturday night
yeah I do honestly feel when you sit
down you decide to turn the TV on and
especially Strictly Come Dancing the
responsibility from the people
performing and and the Heart of that was
Len Goodman from the beginning like he
made you feel welcome he made you feel
like it was just him and you in the room
together not everybody else sat at home
or whatever it was it was just him and
you talking and the one thing that is
really good is he was that Foundation of
Borman Latin he knew what he was talking
about and he always wanted to be if it
was a Cha-Cha it was a Cha-Cha if it was
a wolf it was a Wars I remember my first
dance was a cha cha with Claudia
fragopani and I came on I wanted to
Showcase a little bit I was quite young
and did a great Cha-Cha and we added
some gymnastics in there for her and he
went none of that nonsense I just want
to see the real dancing
yeah stop showing off AJ essentially
but but it
when we look at all of the Victory
judges they've got such you know big
personalities for different reasons but
the lovely thing about Len was however
however Dreadful a dance might sometimes
be obviously never any that you were
involved in but um you know however
challenging the dance might have been he
would always see the positive in it
wouldn't he
a hundred percent he was the best at
giving constructive criticism even when
you thought wow this is um I don't know
how to find positivity in this dance but
he would find it whether that be the
personality the outfit or turning what
was probably a mistake into well that
was obviously planned and everybody at
home is gonna love that don't know how
um you fell on this personal trip over
this but you did and um I loved it
and and you've talked already about how
he changed the way that people saw
ballroom dancing and how he you know
helped encourage people like yourself to
see that this was a career and this was
something that that young men could do
as well as girls I mean with his dance
schools he really brought it to so many
people hasn't he
yeah and I think that's the one thing to
think even Lynn I remember saying this
once was kind of like how can little old
Len be on TV here in front of millions
of people live and in America and his
his phrases have just suddenly become
synonymous with the show more than the
show itself and
he always had that kind of like step
back and realize the honor that he was
actually doing he was representing
ballroom and Latin worldwide and he was
always kind of like wow this is this is
real life you know when somebody says
like this is not real life well this was
real life this was his life and he
didn't change anything and that's what I
loved about himself he was just him
always
and do you think that was partly because
he found Fame late in life he had his
head pretty much screwed on
yeah no probably to do with that yeah
but I I think it was also because every
time he was doing it he came from a
profession if you come from a profession
you feel like you always stick to that
and his comments his were always very
Justified it was always about the
dancing it was always about the art form
that was in front of you so it was never
about Learners in Len it was always
about oh this is the dance that's that's
the personality in the Paso doble show
me the characterism and whenever
somebody's so passionate about their
their profession you just get drawn into
the warmth and he just loved it he loved
his life that's for sure
yeah and it came across on TV it really
did AJ Pritchard lovely to talk to you
uh talking there giving his thoughts
about the passing of Len Goodman thank
you